[Music]
i had
about with breast cancer after the
surgery
oncologist said well sylvia you did well
you know we feel we can give you another
five to ten years of uh
life i said what do you mean five or ten
years i said my grandma lived to be like
a hundred i was a little dejected about
that and
that was always slightly diabetic or
and i really it checked i went from my
doctor's appointment and she said
my a1c had gone up to 10 and it had
never been that high before and i that
really scared me
i said well give me a few few weeks i'll
get it back down
and uh he kind of said well you know
well usually it
doesn't come down you're gonna have to
probably go on insulin i said no give me
a moment i'll get it down
by that time i had found young charity
first year i was starting to see my
weight really dropped
considerably i was really zooming along
so i'm down 62 pounds now
like they weighed me the doctor come in
she says ah
you're down i don't believe this is what
i'm seeing
and i was just tickled in bed you know
my biggest thing about losing weight is
i always wanted to get on the floor and
play with my kids
i never was able to get down on the
floor because of my weight and i have
two two boys that i look after
every day i'm looking forward to being
able to sit
on the floor and cross my legs and have
one of them to sit in my lap
youngerty saves lives we really do
we can lose weight yes me and you